my name is Emil Bala ich and I have an
MSC from the University in electrical
engineering and currently I'm working as
a data scientist at DD labs a sentence
about the day labs we are start-up
providing a platform for big companies
so they can manage their data not based
on file but based on content so today
I'm going to talk about the tension
models for deep network and the best way
I thought I can introduce the topic of
attention models is through a one-minute
video I assume some of you will be
familiar with but it's a good opening
anyway so let's see
how many causes does the team in wine
tonight
think about over okay just a second
yeah just a second yeah that spoiled is
a little bit the front okay no matter
dance I'll try Willie to count it by
yourself okay it's important this is how
many ounces is the team in white
the answer is 13 but did you see the
moonwalking bear
just a second okay so I assume that
those of you didn't familiar with this
video didn't see the bear in the picture
and the reason is that basically the
brain selective attention is our ability
to focus on part of the input which will
which is only relevant to the current
task we are trying to perform today I'm
going to talk about why and how the
brain selective attention is real is
relevant to deep learning I'm going to
explain the motivation about why to
implement model and I'm going to present
two different tasks using attention
models the first will be image caption
generation in which I will use in order
to explain the difference between the
soft and the hard attention and the
second will be text classification for
both I'm going to explain the concept
the implementation and provide some
results so how basically it's relevant
to machine learning let's say that we
want to train some classifier so we can
have we can get many images as an input
and for each for each image we want to
predict which animals which animal
appear in that picture so we have this
huge network of deep deep network with
so many layers the convolutional layer
and the fully connected layers and
finally the soft marks and what we are
doing today is kind of processing that
image through all those networks from
the beginning till to the end and that
makes sense if we have an image that
most of the pixels the pixels are really
the object we are trying to predict but
for example in that case when the object
we are trying to predict is dead bird
here which is basically something like
hundreds of the entire image is kind of
we have a feeling that we can do it much
better if we will be able to just focus
on the part in the image that are really
the object for which is relevant to the
task we are trying to perform so what is
the motivation first the queue we see we
assume if we will be able to just focus
on part of the image which
relevant we can get we can gain more
accuracy we will think that we will see
if this assumption is true second if we
can only process part of the input and
noted all the input we can be we can
gain more moment memory efficiency and
speed fourth is our ability to interpret
and visualize the models functionality
and that's important because then we can
see what really the model was doing at
any prediction and we can observe the
false prediction and to understand
what's going on inside of that model and
last in text specifically we have the
random access memory in which if we can
just take the relevant words or the
relevant parts from the text so we can
process much longer sentences and get
better results and of course the
combination of all the above so well can
we use attention models basically
everywhere I divided the tasks to four
different tasks the first will be one to
one for example image classification
when we have a single input and a single
output which is the class the second
will be one too many for example image
caption generation in which the the task
of image caption generation is the task
when we have an image and we want to
generate some descriptive sentence about
that image so it can tell us what
happens inside that image and we have a
single input which is the image and
multiple outputs which are the world
constructing that sentence
we have many two one for example
document specification when we have
different words as an input and one
classes and output and many-to-many
translation when we have different words
and input and different words as an
output which is the translated sentence
so now I'm going to start talking about
the image caption generation so as I
just mentioned image caption generation
is the task when we are generating some
descriptive sentence which will describe
what what's happening inside an image
and today how we perform this task is
basically constructing from two
different paths two main parts the first
will be the convolutional layers
in which we know that they are very good
in extracting features out of an image
and the output of that layer will be a
some representation vector of feature
vector which we will be used later and
pass it to the next step
the next part is the lsdm chain that
when we know that the LSD ends are very
good with sequential data like we want
to predict the world in a sequential
order so we can really construct a real
sentence out of them so the next part
will be a chain of those lsdm and we
will use them in order to predict the
different words so let's be a little bit
more specific so we have this
convolutional layer and our output
vector and we will use that output
vector in order to fit it to the first
lsdm we will use the soft lsdm and
generate the hidden state that's the
first state then we are going to take
that stay and pass it to the second lsdm
but this time with an additional input
the additional input is the first word
which is which in that case is a special
token indicating to the model that the
next world you need to predict is
actually the first world in the center
so we have these two inputs and we are
going to generate or to calculate two
different outputs the first is just to
update the lsdm state so we can later
pass it on to the next one and the
second will be to calculate the
probability distribution over the entire
vocabulary we have trained on and out of
that probability distribution of a
vocabulary well we are going to take the
word which get the highest probability
and that will be our first word in the
sentence how we calculate the
probability distribution is just a fully
connected layer and applying some
softmax on top of it so now we are going
to move to the next LSP m and now our
input is the world we have just
predicted and the last lsdm state and we
are going to repeat that process we are
going to calculate again to update del
Este instead and to calculate some
probability distribution over vocabulary
from which we are going to now sample
the second word in the sentence and we
will repeat that process until a special
generated which indicates that end of
sentence but actually we have two main
flaws with that model the first one is
that we only get to see the input just
once and we're kind of hoping that this
input is going to propagate through all
these errors all that lsdm or lsdm chain
so it will pass the information on and
it will be cool as if we will be able to
just look at the input more than once
and we know when we are trying to
perform this task
so sometimes we are describing the
background and sometimes we're
describing the object and the operation
and we are looking at different parts in
the input more than one so we really
want to see it more in that model the
second flaw is that we kind of treating
all the pixels as equally important and
while we are predicting different words
we are actually accessing two different
parts of that image sometimes the
background sometimes the object and just
to treat to take the oil images use it
to as a one vector it it's not a very
small thing to do so in order to solve
those problems in 2015 a new paper was
presented called show attendant air and
in that paper they implement the concept
of attention to this task of image
caption generation and the way they did
that it was now instead of just taking
the last vector which is the feature
vector and use it as an input to the
second part LSP M they are now going to
use one of the earlier the output of one
of the earlier layers which is does just
the output of the convolutional layer
itself and now instead of having one
single representation vector we have a
grid matrix which is the output of one
of the convolutional layers in which
each element is correlated or
corresponds to a part in the image
because that's what the convolution does
so now we are going to use that mastery
instead of the previous vector and to
feed it to the next to the first LSP M
so we are going to fit it to the first
LSP M we are going to calculate some
hidden state to pass it to pass it on
and the end now instead of just
calculating the probability distribution
of a vocabulary in order to predict the
next word we are going to calculate
another thing we will calculate the
probability distribution over a
locations all over the L elements in
death matrix which again each element is
correlated to some pop to some part in
the image so we are going to calculate
this probability distribution of the
location but basically what we are
having is which elements of which parts
in the image are more important the
others not as entire for the general
task just in order to predict the next
word so we are going to have this
distribution and we are going to
multiply it with this matrix and now we
are going to feed the weighted matrix
loop which really observing the paths
which are relevant to predicting the
next word and we are going to add it as
a new input to the next state to the
next data stream now we have three
inputs and we are going to repeat this
process we will update the lsdm state we
will calculate the probability
distribution of a vocabulary to guess
our first word in the sentence and we
are going to calculate again the
probability distribution of the
relocation which now can be different
because now we are going to predict the
next word so we are going to repeat this
process until a special token is
generated indicating that end of
sentence so when I talked about the
motivation I said that one of the
motivations was memory efficiency and
speed but when we are observing this
model we kind of see that we only add
Mogul calculations we didn't save any so
that leads me to the next slide which is
the difference between soft and hard
attention and the differences in soft
attentions we basically understanding
which parts in the image are moving
and to predict the next word and then we
just wait the importance and pass it on
we don't extracting any information from
the input we just tell the model where
to look now and that will be soft
attention in hard attention we are going
to understand which one of the paths in
the email drawing the pixels are more
important and to use only those paths
and get rid of and with get rid from the
rest
so if well being a little bit more
specific we have this probability matrix
corresponding to the input matrix and we
are going in soft attention thus just to
multiply each element corresponding and
with her detention what they did in the
paper they just took a single element
out of that matrix
which got the highest importance one
thing to mention about how the tension
is because of that this operation of
taking just one element which has the
highest importance is not differentiable
anymore and you cannot back propagate it
with gradient descent so the intuition
wise that is let's think that we have
the matrix and we have one element with
high value and all the rest of zero and
now we want to gradient descent so we
shake everything a little bit and then
we perform a softmax again so what will
happen we will always choose the same
element as the most important one and
that can kill our model so what they did
in the paper in order to overcome this
problem is to train using reinforcement
learning instead of gradient descent
they are more advanced and I thought out
to overcome this problem for those of
you maybe will try to implement it in
the future so it's called special
transformer instead what they are doing
that instead of just treating this input
as a discrete input the treating is a
continuous input so now what we are
trying to predict is like in
localization just the coordinates the
coordinates which are important to the
task so you have this continuous input
and now they can really gradient descent
it so let's look a little bit about
results that's the interesting part
so we have that image of a bird flying
over some water and we are trying to
predict the different words using that
chain and we can see that while
predicting the world's bird flying and
over the model really ascended to the
word to the world
and why predicting the world's body of
water the model really attends to the
background and that's kind of amazing
because at any step of the way we didn't
tell the model where to attend it just
learned it by itself and that's cool a
little bit more results we have a woman
throwing frisbee in the park so the
model really while predicting the world
frisbee so the model really attend to
that frisbee and with a dog the same and
that's also a nice example when while
the world truth was predicted the model
really attend to the trees in the
background and not to the giraffe in the
center and that's nice a little bit
about accuracy so they did compare the
concept the models with attention to
different other models and they did show
some more accurate results but I think
what's more important is that when they
compare the soft attention with the
heart attention the harder tension
achieved something like something like
one to two percent more accurate results
and I think it's not trivial because in
hard attention we only extract part of
the input and we gain more accurate
results and I will I will be honest that
the there are two main differences
between the soft and the hard one is
really the input which is now different
and the second is the training method
that with harder tension the Train using
reinforcement learning
so which one contributed more I can say
for sure so basically what we have
gained from adding the attention layer
first we saw improvement in accuracy
memory and speed for a detention only
and we can see we get visualization of
the model we can just observe what the
model is really doing at any step so
let's move a little bit to NLP maybe I
will take one question before I move to
NLP
okay so let's go to an LP so now I'm
going to talk about document
classification and to see how we can
implement that concept of attention to
text also and not only to images and it
looks a bit scary and the model I chose
to describe here is a logical network
and in your article network we break the
text into different sentences and
different words it sentences will break
to different words and we build this
hierarchical structure when we have the
first part which is the encoder of the
sentences encoder so we have all the
words and we want to encode in call
encode all these words to a one
representation vector to death sentence
and the way we are doing that is using
the same a LESBIAN lsdm chain so we are
kind of feeding each word sequentially
through this LS TM and in each word we
are sitting we are updating the lsdm
change the lsdm state then we are going
to use this representation vector of
each sentence we're repeating this
process in its thing for each sentence
and we are going to fit it to the second
encoder and again just propagate all
those sentences sequentially through the
LSTs change the output we use in that
case for the representation is the final
state is the final state of that lsdm
and again we are doing that with the
sentences and some details about the
model the embedding we use was glove
embedding and we use a bit Direction
lsdm so we can learn not just from
previous word in the sentence we can get
the concept not just from previous world
but formulated so when we look at that
model we again saw two main floor well
when I said flows it's not like that
model is not working it is but we can
just do it better so the main two
problems is that first we only using the
left
I am state while we can actually use
more of those states we are generating
so we kind of hoped that the entire
information of the sentence from the
different world will propagate through
all the Celestials chains and till the
last output and that may be true from
some short sentences but you can see
when you get two sentences with
something like 30 words and more the
performance decrease exponentially the
second problem is that again we're kind
of treating all the worlds as equally
important we don't tell the model or we
don't apply some layers which need to
understand which of the words are more
important the other and that leads me to
a paper that was presented in 2016
called the radical attention Network for
document classification and in which
they actually implemented two different
things first they took all of the lsdm
states instead of just the last one and
second they add an attention layer and
that is the main core of the paper they
add an attention layer so they are
taking all of those states the lsdm
state and they applied some fully
connected layer on top of that and then
this pulley connected layer they are
going to update the weight during
training and then they apply some soft
marks just in order to understand which
of the states or which of the words in
the sentence are more important not to
represent the sentence but in order to
predict the writes last for the general
tasks we are trying to perform so we are
going to repeat this process one for
words and then for the sentences and in
that way we are going to get which of
the words were more important in order
to predict the final class for example
if the review is negative or positive
okay so which of the words were more
important and then which of the
sentences were more important in order
to make the prediction so I was asked to
show some code I'm going to overview it
briefly we were building this illogical
model but the lair we need to implement
in order to add the attention layer is
this one the attention with concept and
the way to implement it this was done
using chaos is to inherit from some
layer and we need to implement some
functions we have they need for they
need for the initialization the build
function I read those lines so I can
squeeze it in a slide but in the build
we need to define the Westville we want
to update during training and the code
function which is the call of what we
are trying to achieve at the end that's
really implementing those equations so
we have the inputs X which are the
states and the W we are updating we
apply some activation on top of it the
Tongass age and we have the softmax and
then we wait the Vesto so it was a lot
of details and let's look a little bit
about the results and it will make it
clearer so that result is on the Yelp
2013 data set which is basically reviews
of users on different businesses that
specifically is on restaurant and what
we are seeing in that result is that the
world marked in blue are marked in the
model is more important in order to
classify whether a review is negative or
positive and the red bar in the left is
the sentences importance which of the
sentences in more input is more
important in order to understand if the
review is positive or negative so the
left review got 5 stars which is a
positive review and we can see that the
first sentence the the world's delicious
and the sentence marked as I'll
important but in the middle the words I
don't even like which implies some
negative review their sentences got
really low importance and when we
represent that specific review we can
now what happens is we can ignore
completely those those 3 sentences
because the model understand that they
are less important in order
to make the prediction the same to the
right we have the first and the last
which is terrible value terrible value
and they got it descendants got high
importance and the last one I will not
go back which is kind of make sense
because when we having a review most of
the information probably most of the
times will appear at the first sentence
or in the conclusion at the end and in
the middle world kind of blah blah
different things so it really captured
that so it gave the first and the last
one high importance and this is
consistent with what is written inside
so a little bit about accuracy they did
compare the model with different other
models and they showed more accurate
results but what I think is more
important is the comparison between
those three which the differences in the
first they took all of the states and
just average them in the second they
took all of the states and took the max
one and in the last they applied the
attention layer which need to understand
now what's important what's not and then
wait to the input and we can see more
accurate results in about one or two
percentage than the rest which that's
nice so why we a develops really use the
attention model so in except from
accuracy and processing longer sentences
the will reason was the visualization of
the model functionality we had a task
that we needed to classify different
documents whether they are confidential
or not and we understand that if we are
just saying that the document file is
con is confidential or notice just don't
enough we need to understand what
happens inside that file in the content
itself and let's say for example we have
100 pages file and someone in the
organization want to print it but it
can't because it marked as confidential
but when you go inside this file you can
see that there are only three lines
which holds confidential information and
the rest is
so we can allow in some some Advanced
Options for example erase the
confidential part and then you can print
the document or send it another example
is let's say we have a bridge to the
organization and something like ten tens
or hundreds of millions files were
leaked and when we try to evaluate the
damage it's not evaluating you know
which files were leaked you need to
evaluate which content was leaked so
that process on tens of hundreds of
millions of files can take months but if
we can just pin pinpoint you not to the
confidential files but with a
confidential content we can save the
time of evaluation for something like
maybe days and that's great
so well actually today people using
attention layer so the answer is
everywhere in speech recognition in
video captioning question answering
question answering is really cool
because you have a question and then you
can see really where the line that the
model was looking for answering your
question which is really what we are
doing when we have a long text that we
need to answer some specific question
and that leads me to my conclusion which
is when you try to represent some
complex input you can do it better if
you just focus to the part of the input
which has a more relevant specifically
to the task you are trying to perform
[Applause]